Ana: Venimos de una reforma social profunda, pero el país no llegó a 1949 caminando serenamente. Llegó atravesando una guerra civil.
Mateo: Sí. Las elecciones de 1948 enfrentaron a Otilio Ulate y Rafael Ángel Calderón Guardia. La denuncia de fraude, el incendio de papeletas y la decisión del Congreso precipitaron una crisis de legitimidad.
Ana: José Figueres Ferrer lidera la insurrección armada. La guerra dura poco en calendario, pero deja una herida enorme para un país pequeño: muertes, exilios, persecuciones y memoria política dividida.
Mateo: Es importante decirlo: la Segunda República nace de una ruptura violenta. Luego construye instituciones pacíficas, pero su origen inmediato no fue pacífico.
Ana: Termina con pactos: el de la Embajada de México y el Ulate-Figueres. Figueres gobierna dieciocho meses con la Junta Fundadora, y después Ulate asumiría la presidencia.
Mateo: La Junta Fundadora gobierna por decreto-ley y toma decisiones enormes. La más simbólica: abolir el ejército el 1 de diciembre de 1948. El Cuartel Bellavista se transforma en Museo Nacional.
Ana: Ese gesto cambia la imaginación política del país. La seguridad queda en fuerzas policiales subordinadas al poder civil, y el gasto público puede orientarse más hacia educación, salud e infraestructura social.
Mateo: Pero la Junta no solo abolió el ejército. También nacionalizó la banca, una medida muy controversial. Para unos democratizó el crédito; para otros concentró demasiado poder económico en el Estado.
Ana: Ahí se ve que Figueres no era simplemente liberal ni simplemente socialista. Era un reformista con impulso estatal fuerte, pero dentro de una democracia electoral que quería reconstruir.
Mateo: Y por eso el Tribunal Supremo de Elecciones es tan crucial. Después de una guerra por una crisis electoral, el país crea una institución independiente para organizar, dirigir y vigilar el sufragio.
Ana: El TSE es casi una respuesta jurídica al trauma: nunca más dejar la elección en manos del actor político que compite por el poder. Convertir la confianza electoral en institución.
Mateo: Luego viene la Asamblea Constituyente de 1949. Su tarea no era sencilla: recoger tradición liberal, preservar Garantías Sociales, ordenar nuevos órganos y dar estabilidad después de la guerra.
Ana: La Constitución de 1949 combina derechos individuales, propiedad privada, libertad de expresión, recurso de amparo y habeas corpus, con derechos sociales, trabajo protegido, seguro social y función social del Estado.
Mateo: También mantiene la religión católica como religión del Estado, con libre ejercicio de otros cultos. Otra vez aparece la fórmula costarricense: continuidad histórica y cambio institucional en el mismo texto.
Ana: Me parece que la Constitución no es una constitución socialista ni una simple constitución liberal. Es una arquitectura de compromiso: mercado con límites, propiedad con función social, democracia con árbitro electoral fuerte.
Mateo: Y la abolición del ejército le da una condición material especial. Sin fuerzas armadas permanentes, la disputa política se canaliza hacia elecciones, tribunales, Asamblea y, décadas después, Sala Constitucional.
Ana: La Segunda República no borra el conflicto. Lo institucionaliza. Convierte una guerra civil en un pacto constitucional que todavía rige, con reformas, la vida costarricense.
Mateo: Y desde ahí se abre el siguiente ciclo: la socialdemocracia desarrollista, el PLN, el ICE, la expansión del Estado social y, más tarde, la crisis que obligará a abrir la economía.